CBS News contributor Nicholas Thompson
is editor-in-chief of Wired he talked
with Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg
yesterday about the social media Giants
privacy problem and how he plans to
solve it Nick joins us at the table I'm
very curious about the interview but
first I want to know how you got it
especially after this cover can we get a
touch out of this here's your latest
cover of Wired magazine showing him
bloodied and bruised I would think that
you would be the last people he would
reach out to and he did very rarely does
interviews but he reached how did you
get it I think he thought that story was
tough but fair I don't know the internal
conversations they had all I know is
that yesterday I got a note from
Facebook saying we might have an
executive available for you and then in
the afternoon they said can you blue
jeans in to talk with Zuckerberg in ten
minutes in ten minutes so after talking
to him did you think his Mia culpa was
enough I thought it's Mia Copa was
strong and I thought it was the right
thing to do
who knows whether they've done enough to
undo the damage and then there's the
larger question of whether structurally
Facebook can be changed in such a way
that this doesn't happen again one of
the things that he said in your
interview that struck me is he said I
think the feedback that we've gotten
from our community is that privacy and
having dad a lock down locked down is
more important than maybe having more
data and different kinds of experiences
why did you have to learn that from the
community that people valued privacy
over the neat little things you could do
on Facebook well it is a complicated
trade-off right if you prioritize
portability Facebook kind of works
better right you can build more features
you can build better apps it's very easy
to use if you prioritize privacy there's
much lower risk and much lower downside
the country hasn't really prioritized
privacy over the last 10 years it turns
out the privacy line that America
doesn't like to cross is when your data
is used in politics do you get that
since they were caught off guard by this
oh my god they were caught off guard in
all kinds of ways so one they are caught
off guard by the story right this pops
up in 2015 they thought it had gone away
they thought this was the last they were
gonna hear about Cambridge analytic --is
misuse of facebook data then they
learned about it from The Times The
Guardian The Observer and they were
caught off guard by how the public
responded right the story kind of came
out on Friday night Saturday morning
over the weekend I think they thought it
would be bad but passed and was only on
Monday and Tuesday when they realized it
was the disaster of disasters if you
were to take him at his word though
their biggest mistake
was that they were naive right they
thought that that data had been deleted
it really is hard to square that with
the shrewd business behemoth that they
are though yeah that was the that is a
clear mistake right so Zuckerberg
admitted to two mistakes in our
conversation one this specific one when
they learned about it in 2015 they
should have run a forensic audit instead
they asked for legal certification which
is basically like hey do you guys delete
it yeah we did it also if there were
right they should have gone and looked
investigated and looked at all the
computers the second mistake was that
John just mentioned which is the
prioritization of portability over
privacy all right Nick will have a lot
more of this yeah thanks